un nouveau bureau pour marlène schiappa
la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
délocalise son cabinet à l'hôtel de
ville de trappes pendant trois jours ça
me choque pas particulièrement parce que
je suis pas né dans mon bureau au
ministère donc j'ai connu d'autres lieux
de travail je connaîtrais d'autres sans
doute après un bureau de ministères on
n'y est pas tout la journée on est
beaucoup en déplacement au contact des
gens premier contact pour marlène
schiappa une rencontre avec les élus
politiques locaux
objectif trouver des solutions sur
l'égalité est pas là pour faire un tour
de promotion de l'action du gouvernement
je suis là pour surtout vraiment écouter
entendre ce que les gens de trappes
honte à nous dire ce qui peut être
amélioré et ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement pour changer leur vie
quotidienne moi c'est ça mon moteur en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes
mais de façon générale je crois que la
politique elle n'est efficace que si
elle a un impact dans la vie quotidienne
des gens le reste c'est du baratin
la secrétaire d'état s'est ensuite rendu
sur le terrain l'a visité l'antenne du
centre d'information sur les droits des
femmes et des familles
donc on peut soit toutes les victimes
d'infractions pénales que ce soit une
victime de vol d'escroquerie de viol
d'agression sexuelle marlène schiappa
s'est entretenu avec les employés
pendant plus d'une heure pour moi la
politique c'est de l'humain avant tout
donc c'est comment des gens recueil
accueille d'autres gens et parle avec
eux je pense que c'est le nom de nom
c'est bon pour le territoire de trappes
c'est bon pour le gouvernement je pense
que tout le monde a intérêt à jouer le
jeu et a essayé de présenter au mieux ce
qu'il s'y passe en toute honnêteté
avec ce qui fonctionne ce qui fonctionne
moins jusqu'à ce vendredi marlène
schiappa va multiplier les rencontres de
terrain il visitera notamment ce jeudi 3
mai la pépinière d'entreprises
chrysalide une marche dans le quartier
des merisiers est également programmée
ce vendredi 4 mai au matin